welcome back to the show we are taking
your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 our next
caller ace nd 3 1 5 area code caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from hello hi who's this hello
this is a Jay from upstate New York
what's on your mind today my question is
what do you feel is the biggest threat
that the Democrats are facing in the
2018 midterms and terms of retaking the
House and Senate
well the biggest threat is how the line
was just more Donald Trump I'm sorry
what was that last part I just said do
you think it might just be Donald
Trump's that he's just going to keep
coming and coming like the force of
nature is no I don't think so I mean
especially if Trump's approval rating
stays in the high 30s like it is and
even if it drops I don't think that it's
going to be Trump per se you know we've
talked about the major deficit for
Democrats in terms of taking over the
house prior to the next census is it is
because of gerrymandering and I don't
remember the exact numbers Pat it's
always it's hard to say exactly what
Democrats have in past midterms one 54%
of the vote for all House seats but
ended up with under 50% of the seats
part of this as bill Oglesby told us is
because of the urban-rural divide that
exists but a lot of this is because of
gerrymandering that was done after the
2010 census by the then empower
Republicans and that you can do anything
but that is just a mathematical sort of
Boulder that you've got to push up a
mountain and and there's really no way
to undo that until we get another census
in 2020
to answer the cause question I think
that the biggest threat is the fact that
Democrats have to defend seats Senate
seats in states that are clearly red
like North Dakota Montana Indiana it's
going to be hard to hold that ground and
then on top of that try to pick up two
or three seats to get the majority in
the Senate never mind the house right
ever mine ever mine the house yeah so I
think that a lot of the challenges are
sort of mathematical you know if we keep
having a scandal a day and Trump's
approval stays where it is or trickles
down to the low 30
I think that from a political standpoint
there will be lots of Democrats making
good cases for their election one
concern I have is Democrats being their
own worst enemies in terms of candidate
selection there there will probably be
seats at red seats at risk in 2018 and I
hope that Democrats don't exhibit poor
judgment with regard to who wins
primaries and that that's sort of a
concern that's in the back of my mind I
mean historically the first midterm
after a new president is inaugurated is
terrible for the incumbent president's
party yeah usually flips the other way
we saw that with Obama in 2010 the rise
of the Tea Party for example sure so you
know you'd think that history would show
us having some benefits there but we
can't get too overconfident right no no
that the last thing I would do is assume
that that that's going to go our way all
right thanks so much for the call Jake
appreciate it thank you guys all right
take care